the fetus has no choice in being
conceived and is conceived due to the
choices of its parents it seems pretty
clear to me that the baby is a
trespasser the fetus emerges inside the
property of the woman through the
process of conception there is no
boundary for the fetus to cross I don't
want murder to occur but I ask who has
the property rights the mother or the
baby the existence of unwanted
pregnancies does not necessitate a legal
right to violence against the fetus blue
paternalism is a theory not of what is
moral but a theory of what is legal so
I'm trying to find out what is the legal
position on the abortion issue the
resolution reads while the pregnant
woman should be legally required to help
the fetus survive outside her body
whenever that is possible
she should retain the legal right to
evict the fetus at any time during her
pregnancy arguing for the affirmative
Walter block Walter please come to the
stage
[Applause]
arguing for the negative carry Baldwin
carry please come to the stage we will
now close the voting Jean thanks for
having me and thanks for doing the
Lord's work here
I very much appreciate that I am a
professor at Loyola University and
speaking in behalf of most universities
this debate could not occur because it's
hateful somebody's gonna say something
that's hateful and that that's no good
and we can't have anything hateful but
probably we'll have something hateful
here at least in the view of some people
the the way the debate is couched is a
whole sentence there I would just like
to put it down to three words so let me
take a survey here not that I can see
everybody but it seems to me that there
are three positions on on the abortion
issue you can be pro-life pro-choice or
the view that I'll be espousing eviction
is Amanda fiction is a means that you
can evict the fetus but you can't kill
the faeces so just with a show of hands
how many people are pro-life here how
many people are pro-choice how many
people are eviction estates about
one-third one-third one-third and if I
had a fourth choice of you're not sure
I'm sure I'd get 25% there the point I'm
trying to make is that this is a very
divisive issue not only is the general
public divided on on this issue but so
are libertarians now I'm gonna mention
two libertarians who libertarian
credentials am i okay on this thing that
keeps moving around I'm moving it but
what the heck it's okay we're okay good
well if I do it this way when I say Appy
then I then I'll scare everybody keeps
moving not my fault
it's it's its fault I don't like to brag
when it comes to blaming other people
for stuff I'm really good at that Murray
Rothbard
is mr. libertarian and Ron Paul is
another mr. libertarian these are our
two leaders and Murray is pro-choice
Ron is pro-life you can't get two more
libertarian credentialed people than
those two I don't think anyone would
disagree with that and yet they're 180
degrees apart from each other happily we
have me little old me who is going to
solve this problem and it's going to be
a compromised position and it's going to
be a principled compromise position what
do I mean by a principled compromise
position if I say two plus two is six
and you say two plus two is four
a compromise would be two plus two is
five it's halfway between but it's not a
principled compromise because there's
nothing from which you can deduce that
two plus two is five except that it's a
compromise and my claim is that eviction
ism is not only a compromise but a
principled compromise so who would the
ball players in this game well there are
two choices
there's eviction ISM which means taking
the fetus out of the mother's womb and
also killing the fetus those are the two
possibilities it's sort of like what is
the libertarian view on labor unions
well they do two things one of which is
legitimate the other is illegitimate the
legitimate thing that labor unions do is
have a mass quit if you can't quit
you're a slave and just because other
people acquitting doesn't mean you can't
quit so if if that's all they did then
we would support labor unions or we
would think that it's illegal activity
but they do one other thing they call
people scabs and they try to stop the
employer from having raw materials in or
finished goods out or hiring people they
call scabs which seems a little hateful
to me to call them scabs but so the the
lipids are in position on
it depends upon what the labor unions do
well I say that the libertarian position
on abortion depends upon exactly what's
happening and they're just like in labor
unions do who do two very different
things the the situation in abortion
also does two things two very different
things one is to evict the fetus from
the womb and in the third trimester the
fetus will be viable in the first two
trimesters the fetus will not be viable
that's one thing the other thing is to
kill the fetus
now the eviction its position is that
you can evict but you can't kill the
pro-life position is you can not evict
you have to keep the baby in there for
nine months and you certainly can't kill
whereas the pro-choice position is you
can do both you can evict take the fetus
out like when a landlord evict a tenant
for non-payment you just say leave you
don't kill the tenant you just say leave
so the pro-choice position says you can
do both you can evict and you can kill
so what is the libertarian position my
claim is the libertarian position is
eviction namely you can victory but you
can't kill which leads me the question
what is libertarianism if we're gonna
have a libertarian position on something
we have to know what libertarianism is
and the short two-minute version of that
is that libertarians is predicated on
two things one is the non-aggression
principle keep your mitts off of other
people in their property unless you have
their permission sadomasochism is em
joke is the the sadist says to the no.1
the masochist says to say this beat me
and the sadist says no so sadomasochism
is legal not not necessarily ethical
because libertarianism is a theory not
of what is moral but a theory of what is
legal so I'm trying to find out what is
the legal position on the abortion issue
so the knot that's the non-aggression
principle and the other is private
property rights because suppose I would
have grabbed that very nice scarf that
the woman in the front over here is
wearing and I just sort of grab it and
run away with it
did I violate the non-aggression
principle well it all depends upon who
is the rightful owner that scarf
if she's stolen from me yesterday then
I'm just repossessing it now I never saw
the scarf before it's ours it's not mine
so if I stole it from her
it rather if I took it from her it would
be theft because she's the proper owner
of it so we have to have a theory of
proper ownership and the libertarian
theory of proper ownership comes from
John Locke Murray Rothbard Hans hoppy
the people have done great work on that
and it goes back to homesteading who was
there first if you mix your labor with
the land and you put in a corn crop you
own the land and somebody else
domesticates a cow and now has milk and
he owns the milk now you can have trade
and the guy who had the corn field now
owns the milk even though I didn't
produce it but he can trace it back to
legitimate title transfer voluntary
trade free enterprise and private
property rights when does life start
that's an important question my claim is
that life starts with the fertilized egg
the sperm alone will not become a human
being the egg alone will not become a
human being the fertilized egg in the
right environment will become a human
being and we all need the right
environment if we were on Mars without a
spacesuit we'd all die whereas there are
some people who think that the the fetus
is sort of like a cyst or a tumor which
is crazy
I mean if I went around with a gun and I
shot a pregnant woman but I didn't hurt
the pregnant woman I just shot the fetus
and the fetus died I'm not a murderer of
course I'm a murderer that's a vicious
nasty thing whereas if I coercively take
a cut out a tumor of this woman or maybe
grab her and bare her fingernails i
kidnap her I I cut her fingernails
that's different that's very different
then then a fetus a fetus is a person
there's no difference between a fetus
who is one hour from birth and a fetus
who is one hour after birth I have twin
grandchildren one of them I was born
first Robbie he was born first and now
he's out of the womb and his his brother
Ricky is still in the womb there's no
difference between them
just a change of address when you get
born there's no difference so the fetus
is a baby it's a human being so I'm
really pro-life from my best friends of
human beings okay most of them not all
but some most I'm pro-life I wanna I
don't want murder to occur but I ask who
has the property rights the mother or
the baby now take the case of rape
mothers walking along the street she
gets grabbed she gets impregnated and
now this a person not a not a blob not a
tumor a person is growing inside of her
that person is a trespasser a volley an
innocent trespasser the the rapists
father is the bad guy but the the baby
is innocent but he's a trespasser he's
in her property
she's the owner of that property so what
can you do if you have someone in your
house you go back to your house now it's
in the afternoon you're gonna go back to
the house and you find someone in your
house maybe the person is unconscious
you have a right to kill that person no
but you have to keep that person in your
house for nine months or for nine
minutes no you can evict that person I
think you have to call a hospital or an
orphanage if it's a baby you just can't
let the person die I think you have to
evict the person but you don't have to
keep the person in your body you can
evict the person what about voluntary
sexual intercourse doesn't the mother oh
the baby nine months worth of occupancy
isn't there an implicit contract that
she has this now look I'm in favor of
implicit contracts you go to a coffee
shop and you order a cup of coffee you
drink a cup of coffee and they present
you with a bill for a million dollars no
no no no there's an implicit contract
that the price of the coffee has to be
reasonable if it's you know a buck or
two fine and if it's a cappuccino maybe
five bucks but a million dollar bill is
way out of line and there's an implicit
contract that if the restaurant wants to
charge you that I favor price gouging
price gouging is legal look I have a
wristwatch here I bought the ten bucks
on
now offering it for a million anyone
want to buy the swatch from million
bucks
I'm price gouging yeah that's okay but
if I give you the watch and you walk
away with it I can't charge you a
million dollars because we have an
implicit contract that that sort of a
thing can occur so is there an implicit
contract between the mother and the baby
did the mother invite the baby member
I'm talking about voluntary sexual
intercourse now not raped in the case of
rape it's easy that baby is a trespasser
she didn't want the baby there and now
she's got the baby there and she wants
to rid herself of it she didn't want to
kill it just rid herself up and I say
she has a right to do it where's the
pro-life people would say no no she's
got to keep that baby well now when to
voluntary sexual intercourse did she
invite the baby in is there an implicit
contract between her and a baby that
she's got to keep the baby no let me go
back to biology when the sperm enters
the woman's body it takes a little while
for the sperm to get up to the fellow
peein tubes or wherever it gets takes a
half-hour at the point of sexual
intercourse there's no baby remember we
said a baby is a fertilized egg at the
time of intercourse there's no
fertilized egg yet they'll be a
fertilized egg in an hour or a half hour
whenever it is but for there to be a
impulsive contract for it to be any kind
of a contract that have to be two people
the only time the only exception would
they be a host mother you a couple is
infertile they give a sperm to the host
mother or somehow they get a baby and
the host mother she can't evict because
she's got a contract but a voluntary
sexual and of course there's no contract
that can't be a contract because at the
time of sexual intercourse when the
supposin invitation was offered there
was no invitee the invitee doesn't come
about until you get a fertilized egg if
you invite me for dinner tonight at 6:00
o'clock and at around 8 o'clock he's
thought making hints you know you know I
got to get up early in the morning or
something and you sort of want me to
leave do I have a right to stay in your
house for nine months just be doing
trying to feed dinner
no you I have no such right so I favor
eviction ISM
and I've given philosophical libertarian
reasons for it now let me give you some
pragmatic utilitarian reasons for it you
know if you're playing tennis and you
hit to the guy's forehand then you're
losing what should you do try something
different hit to his back in if you're a
football team and the pass isn't working
go to the run try something different
well we pro-lifers or losing guess what
the abortion is all around us that's the
law of the land so if we're losing let's
try something else
let's try Vick ssin ISM that's one
pragmatic reason for you all to adopt
eviction ISM as the correct libertarian
view another pragmatic justification is
medical technology the right now if we
adopt eviction ISM one-third of all
babies are saved now would be nice to
save all of them but it's a compromised
position the pro-life wants to save them
all but it's losing if we adopt eviction
ISM we save in one fell swoop one-third
of all babies in the third trimester you
can't kill anymore
you can only evict and the baby is
viable outside the womb but with medical
technology every 10 years it'll become a
week earlier maybe you know that in in a
hundred years or in a thousand years
babies will be viable all the time and
if we adopt eviction as we'll save all
babies where if we stick our head in the
sand and we stick to the pro-life
position and the the abortion is so
winning we're never going to get out of
this I rest my case
[Music]
[Applause]
Carrie Baldwin for the negative take it
away Carrie thanks Jean I was a typical
pro-life firm
I grew up in the movement memorized the
book on pro-life arguments literally
majored in a scientific field to give me
leverage I was convinced that winning
the abortion debate was entirely about
logic I got married got pregnant and
left my newly budding career to become a
stay-at-home mom I continued debating
abortion in online forums but as I
started listening to women explain the
reasons for seeking abortion my
perspective began to change I was still
pro-life but the solution was no longer
clear it was ambiguous so much so that I
stopped talking about abortion for
roughly 10 years in 2016 I sought a
divorce from what I came to realize was
an abusive marriage despite having a
degree I couldn't get a traditional job
certainly not one conducive to the life
of a single mother one day I came across
a YouTube video from a new anti-abortion
group it was a battle plan to make
abortion first-degree murder even if it
meant the death penalty for the woman a
war on abortion I heard would look like
the war on drugs as libertarians we know
why this cannot happen so I broke my
silence with a constructive criticism of
the pro-life movement the issue is now
clearer to me you see I had lived
through what so many women are trying to
avoid when seeking abortions poverty and
an abusive relationship conflict in this
issue still exists and is escalating for
one reason compromise both sides
compromise rights pro-lifers compromise
women's rights in favor of the fetus
pro-choicers compromise fetal rights in
favor of the woman so doctor blocks
offer of a principled compromise rings
hollow to me it seems to me that we need
more than a compromise I agree that
property rights are the key to resolving
the legal question of abortion but I
disagree with the resolution a
compromise even a principled one begets
ambiguity Marie Roth
cards purpose and using proper property
rights was to show human rights are
unambiguous toward the son die argue the
that fetal eviction is illegitimate for
two reasons the fetus cannot be a
trespasser and claiming such diminishes
women's rights allow me to explain
eviction ISM is grounded in the
aggressive act of trespass a trespasser
is someone who crosses a boundary
without the property owner's permission
in this case they also use the property
owner for life support but it's the
fetus a trespasser no first the fetus
never crosses a boundary sexual
intercourse doesn't put someone in the
property of the woman sperm are only
gamete cells the fetus emerges inside
the property of the woman through the
process of conception there is no
boundary for the fetus to cross
besides this studies in human embryology
have found women don't control fetal
development the fetus does it's
autonomous and self-organizing in other
words the product of human conception is
a human that exhibits direct and
immediate control over its own body it's
a self owner and it originates inside
the property in question
second the fetus doesn't need permission
to emerge a woman changing her mind
about pregnancy is compared to informing
dinner guests that it's time to leave
guess meat permission to continue their
stay or else it's trespass but granting
permission is not relevant to conception
because no woman grants permission for
conception to occur conception is 8
sometimes unwanted yet involuntary
process
suggesting a woman invites or disinvites
a fetus projects onto the woman power
she does not naturally have that is to
voluntarily grant her rescind conception
more to the point of granting permission
were relevant than all fetuses are
trespassers we all would have come into
this world as criminals
since no woman grants permission for
conception to occur and if prohibiting
pre viable eviction is forced altruism
then not evicting is necessarily
altruistic so if all fetuses are
trespassers and all women who choose not
to evict or acting altruistically
then human rights are contingent not
absolute grounded in the voluntary
altruism of another not in self
ownership the invitation analogy is
invalid we cannot call the fetus a
trespasser the better analogy is the
economic concept of production
specifically that a woman owns the means
of producing new self owners but it's
the woman obligated to provide life
support to a fetal cell phone ER to
answer this we must ask if the fetus has
an absolute right to life support in
this case food and shelter
this is invariably where rape comes up
volitional course can volitional
intercourse can produce new self owners
but so can rape so let's speak in
volitional terms first the fetus is a
self owner but it's not yet an actor in
other words the fetus cannot yet choose
a necessary feature of human nature is
developing the capacity to act no cell
phone er chooses to become a self owner
the fetus has no choice in being
conceived and is conceived due to the
choices of its parents even when its
conception was unintended what dr. block
and others have interpreted as an act of
fetal trespass is actually the naturally
created positive obligation the fetus
holds against its parents since their
action initiated the process that
resulted in the fetuses self ownership
drawing life support from the woman is
not an act of aggression it's the
natural right of the fetus it's
important to understand this about
conception it's an involuntary reflexive
process initiated by sexual intercourse
and results in the only product of human
action to come equipped with its own
rights but dr. block says libertarianism
opposes positive obligations positive
law forces conformity to tradition or
codifies arbitrary whim these uses of
the law are indeed anathema to
libertarianism
but Rathbun said we establish legal
principles by discovering the natural
law understanding natural woman is so
vitally important here Roth words
position on positive law can actually be
grounded in the natural maternal-fetal
relationship in other words the reason
why we
cannot arbitrarily create positive
obligations is because we lack the
proprietary interest to do so the state
is literally not our mom positive
obligations in parent-offspring
relationships are compatible with
libertarianism because they're derived
from the natural law so what about the
woman's property rights this is one area
where pro-lifers consistently fail but
libertarians can get right one thing
that sets us apart as humans is our
ability to choose against instinct and
impulse and in this case to rationalize
sexual relationships acting woman takes
into account all that goes on within her
own body as well as other data from her
environment she can neutralize bodily
factors within certain limits to get her
body under control her abstaining from
these things are also purposeful action
is the manifestation of a woman's agency
and her agency is paramount a woman owns
a particularly unique feature of human
proliferation she owns the means of
producing new self owners her agency
entails a choice here the eviction
astaire errs supposing that women have a
right to choose which self owners will
be evicted but this implies that our
rights of self ownership are contingent
on our mothers altruism
that's matriarchy not libertarianism
rather women have a right to choose
whether they'll use their property to
produce new self owners but her right to
choose not to produce new self owners is
naturally limited in the case a new self
owner is produced inside her her choice
also entails using means to prevent
conception and there are good reasons to
prevent conception but some methods of
contraception are not guaranteed using
these means assuming the risk and
unintended consequences should
contraception fail a woman bears the
greater cost in reproduction which means
contraceptive failure is a greater risk
to her
this is nonetheless her choice this
choice necessarily involves assuming her
own risks an unwanted pregnancy from
volitional intercourse is one unintended
consequence she assumes but can she be
relieved of this natural obligation yes
there are of course many reasons for
unwanted pregnancy not wanting to be
pregnant
is a legitimate desiring goal but the
legal obligation to life support must be
emancipated either naturally or
prematurely natural Mansa patient is
simple it's the child developing into an
adult premature emancipation is a
transfer of natural obligations to a
voluntary surrogate it excludes
transfers and transfers that necessarily
involve death of the offspring so
obviously this excludes pre viable
emancipation this is not a denial of the
woman's property right in her body it's
consistent with a natural limitation
created when a new self owner is
produced this is most there's most
definitely a market need created for the
convenience of emancipating as early as
possible this is consistent with the
state of nature where without any
technology the earliest possible
emancipation is at birth so what happens
when reproduction takes place through
coercion and violence
what about rape current definitions of
rape all seemed to miss the mark they
failed to grasp the self ownership of
the woman to do justice in situations of
rape we must understand how fetal
self-ownership reveals what's at stake
so let's bring this full circle a woman
owns herself she owns the means of
producing new self owners this entails a
myriad of choices that a woman has a
right to determine within natural
limitations
sexual intercourse can initiate the
involuntary reflexive process of
conception the results in the production
of a new self owner and therefore
creates a natural obligation what does
rape do then rape denies a woman's self
ownership rape seizes control of her
means of production rape denies a
woman's determination and power to
control her body her associations assume
her own risks and imposes all intended
and unintended consequences on her rape
dehumanizes in the misison sense since
the consequence of the physical sexual
and psychological trauma causes her to
behave more from impulse instinct and
reflex
that's what rape does rape is not merely
non-consensual sex rape weaponized sex
add to this
fact that rape can initiate the
involuntary reflexive process of
conception we've been told these are
reasons why pre viable eviction or
abortion is justified in the case of
rape but these are actually the rights
violations by the rapist presenting
eviction as the necessary remedy for
rape diminishes the crime of rape rape
slips out the back door while we're busy
arguing about whether the fetus is a
criminal or a person or alive
forget the fetus for a moment eviction
or abortion for rape creates an inherent
injustice against women our current
legal system manifests this injustice
think about it in a state of nature
where there is no technology for
contraception abortion or eviction or
there is no legal system if curso rapes
Jane who was forcing Jane to carry an
unwanted fetus crusoe this is not the
crime of the fetus it's not even the
legal force of the state by using
coercion or violence Crusoe violates
Jane self-ownership denying her agency
and dehumanizing her he seizes control
of her means of production and he
creates a natural limitation on her by
initiating through force the involuntary
reflexive process which produces a new
self owner within her property line and
against her will
it's the rapists use of force at play
when a woman carries an unwanted fetus
from rape it's the rapist restricting
the woman's liberty interest the legal
principle we can deduce here is not
eviction because the fetus is not the
criminal the legal principle deduced is
restitution owed by the rapist to the
woman into the fetus restitution is
about making the victim whole again but
you can't do this by granting license
for one victim the woman to do violence
to a second victim the fetus and the
fetus is not doing violence to the woman
it can't even act in fact granting such
license is using positive law to codify
arbitrary whim since it's not within the
power of natural woman to end fetal life
now
it's foolish to suppose that writing a
law will end a behavior ending abortion
can only be achieved by mitigating the
felt need for it but the existence of
unwanted pregnancies does not
necessitate a legal right to violence
against the fetus it does necessitate
free market solutions a free market
empowers women but the fetus cannot be a
trespasser it doesn't cross the boundary
it doesn't need permission to be
conceived and it has a natural right to
life support
fetal trespass diminishes women's rights
it reinforces the lie that rape is a
passing moment that sometimes leaves
women with nothing more than an
inconvenient moral conundrum the whole
point of a libertarian theory of
abortion is to disambiguate this issue
the status quo of women's rights is
already compromised our rights have
always been subjugated to the rights of
men the interest of the state or the
church or even our offspring using
property rights to absolute as fetal
rights absolute eise's women's rights a
libertarian legal order demands justice
for the woman it demands the rapists pay
for his crime and it denies the
illegitimate use of force even by women
women's rights do matter but we cannot
see them clearly until we draw a line in
the sand women have the most to gain
from a freed market and a libertarian
legal order but not if we're left with a
compromise thank you
[Applause]
five minutes already put it from Walter
you get up there if you want
I must have published Oh 15 or 20
articles on on this subject mostly in
very prestigious um prestigious law
reviews other less prestigious law
reviews and also in many scholarly
journals on property rights and yet I
think that her view on this is easily
equal to the best of them and probably
better than most of them so I'd like a
round of applause for her the problem
with this from my point of view is I'm
much more visual than auditory I'm much
better at reading something than I am at
hearing and I don't know that I'll do
full justice because this is the first
time I've heard this so I order you to
write this up
stick stick in a few footnotes and get
it published and then I'll be able to do
much better justice to your views than I
am now so please forgive me if I don't
fully understand everything but I'll do
my best I agree with what she said about
abortion being first-degree murder it is
first to promote it because remember how
I define abortion is eviction is
implying so if you kill innocent people
and the fetus is innocent you're a
murderer and the doctor who does that is
accessory to murder or what I'm not sure
what the legal term is but he's a bad
guy and the woman is a bad guy for for
killing when she did not kill in the
third trimester that baby is viable
outside the womb and they kill the baby
with partial birth abortion that is
perhaps the most despicable thing known
to man well maybe there other despicable
things but that that's high up on the
list it's a tear apart a little baby and
pull the baby out is just horrible and
yet but that's what the law allows now I
didn't really get the idea of ambiguity
I I think that this is not an
you us at all it clearly says that you
can evict but you can't kill I don't see
any ambiguity there yes there's some
ambiguity in the sense that the baby and
the first two trimesters will die
whereas in the third trimester it won't
but I don't see that ambiguous it seems
pretty clear to me that the baby is a
trespasser now my learning opponent says
all fetuses are not trespassers well I
would say all unwelcome fetuses are
trespassers
she says none of them are trespassers
you need altruism but take the case of
rape the woman is walking down the
street she gets grabbed she gets
impregnated and that is a person growing
inside of her now it's true that that
person isn't doing it purposefully he's
innocent he's not you know cutting her
or hurting her not purposefully anyway
he's kicking a little for me but when my
kids were born my wife was kicked from
the inside baby's kick but you know
we're not gonna count that as violence
but but you don't have to be violent to
be a trespasser look suppose I make
someone unconscious an adult and I stick
him in your room that person is a
trespasser he's innocent he didn't do it
i drugged him and I stuck him in in your
apartment or in your house so I don't
think you have to do anything
to be a trespasser so you just have to
occupy someone else's property without
their permission and it seems so clear
to me that in the case of rape that's
exactly what the fetus is doing now this
business of positive obligations again
I'm not sure I'm doing justice to my
learning opponent but we lipid turns see
positive rises in a coma I mean now you
have welfare rights the right to food
right to clothing right to shelter right
to this right to that the only rights
compatible with libertarianism on
negative rights we all have a right not
to be murdered we all have a right not
to be stolen from we all have a right
not to be raped that we all have a right
not to be assaulted unless we agree to
be in the boxing match and someone
punches us in the jaw
you can't call assault and battery
because you agree to be in the boxing
match
but apart from that we only have
negative rights if we had positive
rights then the welfare system would be
justified so I don't see that anyone and
the baby the the fetus the the child
who's three months in the in the
mother's womb is a baby with all the
rights that other people have and the
only right that anyone has including a
baby in inside the womb a preborn baby
is not to be murdered but yes it's true
then in the first two trimesters if you
evict the baby the baby will die but
that's justified because the because we
have a choice between who is the proper
owner of the woman's body is it the
fetus or is it the mother well the
mother was say at first homesteading
theory says that the first owner of the
property is the owner of the property
the fetus came afterward the mother is
so 25 years old the fetus is 25 minutes
old or 25 days old or 25 weeks old she
owns that body and if somebody is
sitting there not doing violence but
just sitting there that's a violation of
property rights look you can have a lot
of crimes that are not violent
pickpocketing is very delicate fraud is
very delicate bad check writing you
don't have to have punching or shooting
to be a criminal you can have non
violent criminality that baby is a
criminal an innocent criminal but a
criminal
five minutes of rebuttal from Carrie so
there are two nuances at play in this
debate the negative right to not be
aggressed against in the question of
positive obligations a woman carrying an
unwanted fetus is not merely upholding
the fetuses negative right
she is also passively providing shelter
and a food supply passive action is
still action and we certainly didn't
want to avoid establishing a principle
which makes lawful the positive
obligation to provide food and shelter
or anything else for that matter to any
random person in dr. blocks view the
only way to do this is to reject any and
all notion of positive obligations and
the only way to achieve this in a
situation of unwanted pregnancy is to
declare the fetus at criminal of some
kinds granted an innocent one - to do
this dr. block begins with the strongest
premises from both sides of the abortion
debate the woman's bodily autonomy and
the fetuses rights bearing status he
then employs the situation of rape to
derive a rule for unwanted pregnancies
and volitional situations now this is
common practice in philosophical
argumentation to begin with the hardest
case and there's no doubt in my mind
that rape is the hardest case of
unwanted pregnancy but why is rape the
hardest case because it's the equivalent
of someone temporarily stepping on your
property and leaving you with an
inconvenient moral conundrum or is rape
the hardest case because of the
implications of absolute self ownership
if our rights of self ownership are
absolute then we conclude we're dr.
block begins where dr. block assumes
these premises for the sake of making a
cogent argument I'm reiterating why
these premises are true in the first
place eviction ISM contradicts the
absolute rights of self ownership if it
says we all began our lives as criminals
and the only reason why we weren't
justly evicted was because her mother's
altruistically ignored our crimes
against her a woman should never put up
with a crimes against her but the fetus
is not committing a crime the fetus
cannot be a trespasser
it doesn't cross a boundary it doesn't
need permission to be conceived it has a
natural right to life support this
obligation may be legally transferred to
a surrogate but not at the cost of the
offsprings life the fetal right to life
support food and shelter is only held
against the parents it's not held
against any other person the positive
obligation exists in a closed circuit
which explains why positive obligations
cannot be legislated by anyone no
outsider can legally invent children's
rights and thus centrally plan the
family and no outsider is legally
obligated to provide life support for
children if we are not honest about what
is inherent and natural woman that she
owns the means of producing new self
owners then we undermine the rights of
women and both sides of the abortion
debate have done this the conservative
pro-life view errors by relegating women
to the secondary status of incubators
existing for their utility because of
what men are biologically incapable and
capable of in cases of rape they
emphasize moral heroism for keeping
those babies this also diminishes the
crime of rape by romanticizing it the
pro-choice view has relegated women to
secondary city status by perpetuating
the lie that the remedy for unwanted
pregnancy is violence
meanwhile rape remains the least likely
of violent crimes to get a conviction
and where there is a conviction rapists
are often given leniency rape culture is
not a product of male privilege it's a
product of state privilege and judicial
malfeasance the eviction ax steal is
self-defeating it doesn't uphold
Rothbart it falsifies him rothbard was
correct about property rights as human
rights but he Mis applied it to abortion
doctor blog is correct about trespass
but he miss applies it to the fetus my
view resolves these anomalies it takes
into account the right of women to
choose what to do with their bodies
within natural limitations while
revealing for us why rape is such a
horrific rights violation absolute izing
fetal rights absolute Isis women's
a libertarian theory of abortion should
not attempt to compromise the existing
failed paradigm what the existing
paradigm gets wrong is their presumption
of the inevitability of rape and their
distorted sense of justice
libertarianism corrects the paradigm by
absolute izing the self ownership of
both women and offspring and this means
fetal eviction is illegitimate as the
libertarian theory thanks thank you to
both and we now get to the Q&A portion
of the evening and think we have a mic
where people can line up I do have a
couple of questions as much for
moderators prerogative but meanwhile
we're pretty open-ended and if either if
you want to put a question to the other
then you can do so at any time or
perhaps you want to wait for the
questions and then see but anybody
wanting to exercise that prerogative at
this moment to ask question whether I
have a criticism of carry my gratitude
question my criticism is you chose me
dr. block okay yeah yeah yeah I would
like her to call me Walter and invite me
to call her Carrie that's my big
criticism okay yeah that's well taking
Walter and and then otherwise I have a
couple of questions for Carrie first my
puzzle is this sort of a critical to a
question if where children are wanted
where the fetus is wanted where it was
intended to have a kid and raise the kid
then presumably that's not altruism on
the part of the mother that's just
that's the desire to be a mother
and therefore the mother does not regard
the kid as a trespasser but a sort of a
welcome visitor and therefore if I
understood you correctly you said when
that the implications of the eviction
ISM and that all babies are brought into
this world as criminals presumably not
in the case of where you know if you and
I were ever wanted by our mothers then
we were not criminals when we were born
would that be valid as far as you're
concerned what I just said but as far as
wanted children children who were wanted
okay they're not wanted by altruist
they're wanted by people who want to
become mothers and similarly they're not
what they are since they wanted they're
not regarded as trespassers they're
welcome visitors so would that be valid
as far as you're concerned to the extent
that the kids are wanted so I don't
think that that wanted is the condition
necessary because you have you have
situations where women want to get
pregnant and they can't yeah and so I
emphasize the fact that conception
itself is an involuntary process because
you can want it to occur and it won't
occur if you're you know if you struggle
with infertility so not wanting it can't
be the other condition if if you engage
in a volitional intercourse then there
are natural consequences to volitional
intercourse and maybe you don't want to
experience all of those potential
consequences which is why we use
contraception but contraception isn't
guaranteed which means that if
contraception fails were subject to the
natural consequences that may occur so
wanted miss isn't really the condition
necessary for understanding the rights
of the fetus because ultimately wanted
miss is still an aspect or an element of
altruism you either want to extend mercy
to to a child or you don't do you either
want to have a family or you don't
but if our rights are based in self
ownership and rothbard said that that
self ownership is at is absolute and
primordial by the way although I think
he intended that in the historical
meeting but I intend it in the
biological meaning if our rights are
absolute then part of what forbids her
from evicting pre-viability specifically
has to be based in something absolutely
which and not something contingent like
whether or not she wants it does that
make sense not sure but I'll let the
test you have a comment Walter to make
or do you want going well I agree
absolutely with
the point that you're making I wish I
had made that shut up I couldn't make I
think it's absolutely true that if the
baby is wanted it's not a criminal he is
not I shouldn't say it's the baby it's a
person he or she is not a criminal I
just wanted to add one thing about this
crossing a boundary look um I have this
power I'm gonna shoot you people and
what's gonna happen is you're all gonna
get pregnant the men too by the way men
can get pregnant according to the latest
politically correct thing men can get
pregnant and also there's only about
women so stick to the plan and can get
pray all those choices are never got
pregnant in one of the movies remember
so men can get pregnant now what I'm
doing is I'm shooting you all with this
ray gun
I've got magical powers and now there's
a baby growing inside of you did he
cross a boundary I don't know I don't
care I don't think crossing a boundary
is the key to trespassing it doesn't
matter how the baby got into you the
baby is into you you didn't want that
baby the baby is a trespasser so I I
can't go along with carries view that
there has to be a boundary crossing that
the only boundary that got crossed in
the case of rape is the sperm went into
the woman's body so but then that's not
the baby the baby doesn't come about
until there's a fertilized egg so okay
I'll grant to her that there's no
boundary crossing but I don't think that
a boundary crossing a boundary crossing
is sufficient but it's not necessary to
be a trespass again I'm shooting you now
and you're all pregnant and there was no
boundary crossing except this ray gun
that I shot but the baby came from
within you the baby didn't cross any
boundaries the baby just erupted or Gav
came to life inside of you do to my
magical powers the baby is still a
trespasser even though there was no
boundary crossed all right Kari just one
final question for you as well
with respect to rape I understand you
correctly you're saying that the rapist
violated the woman the fetus is innocent
bystanders and victim of the
circumstance and that the woman should
bare the baby to term but then claim
restitution of the rapist is that is
that correct
I would say that she has I would use the
word emancipate instead of evict and she
would have a right to emancipate post
viability so she could still deliver
early in order to in order to not have
to deal with you know an unwanted fetus
from rape but her the the crime against
her right with with the rape doesn't
give her the the power to then use
violence against the fetus what she's
owed what the woman is owed is
restitution from the rapist well yes I'm
sure but but but then here you say you
you prefer to use the word emancipate
the woman can emancipate the fetus from
her body did you say that yes okay in
that it was Walter would characterize
that as victor fetus from her body so so
in the case of rape it's just kind of a
semantic difference between you and and
Walter is that correct yeah I think most
of our district difference is
pre-viability oh well pre-viability I
would say all about the differences are
pre-viability we agree a hundred percent
on Postma liability namely the woman can
emancipate or evict or eject or what if
you want to call it that's just
semantics the key is in the first two
trimesters now but with medical
technology everything it'll be a little
but but the first two trimesters are
okay with you in the case of rape is
that right yes no she's she's hablen
because this song because that's a self
owner and that self owner has the right
to life she should the baby at a time
not not necessarily to term she can she
can emancipate but the cost should be
the the cost should be written off on
them on to the ratio should bear the
baby so that the baby survives is that
right yes baby's got to survive okay
baby's gonna survive whether it's to
viability or to term there's got to make
sure the baby survives even that's rape
okay right all right I'll have a
question can I ask Karen question fine
do you acknowledge that my position is
better than the pro-choice position is
it better better from your perspective
Monteux one-third agreed if not
two-thirds yes okay good yes thank you
one third better okay question yeah
take what you can get
take it away just ask the question I've
been for dr. block I believe was Walter
Walter Walter Walter I believe that his
argument is basically grounded in
contract that's what he said
and I think of key to that is the fact
that there is no party to contract with
when the act is right your question is
what what question is what about the
concept of a tortious creation of life
the act of either the the man or both
result in say a negligent creation of
life and so the fetus could be owed a
duty under under a tortious Theory
tortious Tork yeah they torched teo ort
a tortilla that the that the negligent
or irresponsible or responsible act of
the party or parties involved resulted
in this life being created and the fetus
is now incurs all sorts of obligations
to to itself that are not it's its fault
it's the fault of others it's you know
there's no no contract basis needed here
it's it's like if I hit my uh if I hit
somebody with my car
I owe them a duty even though I had no
contract with them so that's I'm just
wondering you know how does the you know
you could have a toy okay questions well
I certainly agree that if you hit
somebody by accident not on purpose if
it's on purpose it's a crime I'm sure
you'd agree with me Bette but if you hit
somebody with your car by accident you
owe them a tort namely you have to
repair the car and certainly pay their
medical bills if needed but I don't see
that you owe any foetus anything because
you didn't commit anything against them
namely you improved the fetuses position
it seems to me because you gave it him
life so I think you're the benefactor of
the fetus even if the fetus only lives
for a couple of weeks so I would reject
the point but I think it's a
important point so I thank you for it
carry any comment to the question well I
would object to even the notion of
implied contract or implied consent
because you know again a woman doesn't
actually invite can invite the fetus
into her body this is an involuntary
process and what's interesting is that
when you start talking about invitation
or implied consent that incidentally is
language that gets transferred over into
rape situations where we're asking did
the woman invite the rape so I would say
that there is no even implied contract
between the woman and the fetus you have
to know when you've entered into a
contract neither the woman nor the fetus
has any such knowledge so I wouldn't
even use that kind of language like
question for Kerri and Walter in terms
of legal government legal policy should
there be a precise point such that up to
that point anything goes and after that
point is first-degree murder or should
it be a gray zone associate up to point
a anything goes remember you can
disagree morally or humanely if you want
and after point B its first-degree
murder but in between there's a rising
scale of penalties and hoops you have to
jump through to get around the penalties
starting with misdemeanors and bigger
misdemeanors and so forth question yeah
I I do understand the question I don't
have to repeat it because every I'm
trained to repeat questions but everyone
heard the question yes as well as I did
yeah I I would say that Kari and I agree
if I can put words in her mouth that in
the third trimester there should be no
crime of evicting because the baby will
be alive we just disagree in the first
two trimesters and she says that it
would be a crime not just a moral but an
actual crime to evict the baby in the
first through Toronto cities the baby
will die and I say yes the baby will die
but it's a true compromise position that
I'm offering a principle one I think so
I think that if you evict
you can evict the baby at any time okay
I guess just can't kill the baby ever
okay baby will die in the first two
trimesters but that's that's legitimate
according to libertarianism as I
understand I think the question was you
know just I guess the the the gray zone
between when when the second trimester
ends the first one starts again I guess
Walter you would basically say that that
the the physicians and the presiding
would be obligated to try to make get
the baby to live and and if it's the
best efforts then the courts don't the
law doesn't have to be involved right so
doctors should think their best efforts
and the woman to keep the baby alive
there were these cases that Ron Paul
talks about where the baby is viable and
they put the baby in a bucket and let
the baby cry and die I mean that's sort
of SuperDuper disgusting you could be I
guess there could be some gray hairs do
you have a comment K yeah I do um one
thing that I I noticed when I was
studying your papers Walter had a girl
was that you know you've got this
distinction this eviction plus killing
right and one thing that I learned in my
research was that the way abortion has
been done in the past or at least one of
the the methods was literally eviction
plus killing like the the mother would
actually be given medication to induce
early and the it would be done by a
perinatologist not an abortionist
and she would deliver the the fetus it
wouldn't be viable but they would treat
it as they would a miscarriage and so
the woman was given an opportunity to
grieve the baby she would hold it until
until it died that sort of thing but the
way that abortion is done now is much
much different you don't have the
distinction of eviction plus killing
it's a distinction really of killing
Plus removing a dead body I mean even
the the the two most common methods of
abortion in those first two trimesters
you have medical abortion which is where
they use a drug that's typically used
cancer which causes the fetus to detach
from the uterine lining and it starves
and suffocates the fetus and then she
takes the second pill that that
basically induces labor and she expels
expels of dead fetus so that's not a
vixen plus killing that's killing plus
evacuation of a dead body
the other one is surgical which is using
a vacuum to to dismember so neither of
those two methods really fit the that
distinction anymore of eviction plus
killing it's it's a completely different
method you ever comment Walter well I
think Harry knows a lot more about this
situation than I do so I defer to what
she said okay question yeah I'd like to
know what the two of you think about
severely disabled fetuses okay
yeah sure thank you for that question
you know there are a multitude of
disabilities that a fetus can can
develop and I think the question that we
need to ask ourselves is do disabled
people still have a right to live even
if it's a short term even if it's you
know even if it's going to be a
difficult life now do we get to make
that choice if I see a disabled person
in the audience do I get to make the
choice of whether that person whether
their life has value or not no of course
not they have a right to into their own
property their own self ownership and so
even a a baby that has disabilities
would would still have retained that
right of self ownership there are other
disabilities that are that are so
difficult that they are said to you know
not that they're not going to have a
very long life and in that case usually
what happens medically speaking
is the the nurse the doctor they might
opt to have an early delivery and allow
the parents to enjoy the life with that
with with their baby even though it's
eventually going to die that's still
something that's still granting an
understanding that they have that right
to self ownership even if it's a short
life lived we don't all have a guarantee
that we're going to live a long life and
if we don't have a guarantee that we
that we're going to live a long life
that shouldn't cut short our right to
ourself ownership in our life I agree
with Carrie 100% which shouldn't be any
surprise because with both liver turns
and we agree on ninety nine point eight
percent of everything and we just
disagree on one or two things one that I
know about I wanted to add to what
Carrie said with which I agree
wholeheartedly and enthusiastically
there was this case in Florida where
there was a common toast woman and she
was brain dead which you can't get more
disabled than that and she was brain
dead and the husband wanted her to
wanted to pull the plug and the reason
was he had another lady he wanted to
marry and if she was still alive it
would be bigamy and he couldn't marry
the other lady and the judge
unfortunately went along with him my
view with the relation of parents and
children is you can't own the child but
you can own the right to bring up the
child namely to be the Guardian how do
you maintain the right to be the
guardian of the charm by guarding well
if the husband wanted to pull the plug
that shows immediately that he's no
longer the Guardian the parents wanted
to keep the plug in there because a
miracle might occur and they were
willing to pay the cost of it and I
think that the judge erred in saying
that the plug could be pulled as long as
this one person on the planet that wants
to save her and is willing to pay for it
she should have been allowed to stay
alive because who knows a miracle could
occur tomorrow they could come up with a
cure for brain-dead or whatever whatever
the problem is so I support Kerry
entirely on this one next question hi I
don't hear any reference to punishment
for abortion and let's say the first
trimester
a libertarian or ancap view would never
be a proponent for country a innovating
country B for doing something country a
didn't like so it seems to me that it's
the same of police arresting a woman
getting an abortion it seems to me a
consistent libertarian could never be a
pro-life because that would require the
state the involvement of the state you
get the general drift for that question
Carrie yes I'm really glad that you that
you asked me that question so obviously
we're talking about a libertarian legal
order and I'm even personally myself a
libertarian anarchist and in an
anarchist Society you still have a legal
order it's called a polycentric legal
order but you know if you were to ask me
how this current government should
should enforce an abortion ban I would
say it can't okay and an authoritarian
government is incapable of enforcing a
libertarian idea because they're using
positive law because they because of the
police state I mean one of them one of
the big concerns and it is a legitimate
concern I think is that with a police
state in an authoritarian situation if
we're treating a war on abortion like
the war on drugs then you have to
consider even miscarriages as suspect
and that's that is a nightmare and so if
you're going to ask me what should what
should the state do now it should not
touch me and leave me alone and we need
to keep a libertarian legal order
because otherwise it's just six and one
half dozen and the other they're either
going to violate the rights of a woman
you know in in we've seen that happen in
the drug war I don't need to really
describe that but they're either going
to violate the rights of women or
they're going to violate the rights of
the fetus so what we need to do to
actually implement this is work on the
freed market and getting a libertarian
legal order now once that libertarian
legal order is in place you have things
like presumption of innocence for
example you know so you don't have a law
enforcement agency
that is suspicious of everything and if
somebody has evidence that a woman has
has had an abortion and they want to
charge her with that they would
obviously have to go through a legal
process go to you know in a legal
dispute a third third party dispute
agency is the term they use for
anarchism so that process would still
occur but you don't have the situation
that you would have now where
miscarriages are suspect and you know
we're using women as informants and
trying to make favors and still throwing
them in prisons I mean the victims of
the drug war are the drug users right
the victims of a war on abortion would
be women there's one person who stands
in between the fetus and the rest of the
world and that's the woman and so I
wouldn't I could not dream of a police
state enforcing in any sort of ban on
abortion you probably agree with that
Walter oh absolutely not
I'm lucky with this I was gonna say I
hate to ruin the debate by agreeing with
her once again but here happily I
disagree with her I think that if you
get an abortion in the third trimester
you're guilty of first-degree murder
you're a murderer now it might be hard
to catch you I don't care about that
that's just pragmatic utilitarianism
stuff I'm interested in libertarian
justice you are a murderer if you abort
a baby that could live outside the womb
period but I wanted to add this thing
about one country invading another
country I was once in a debate with
Richard Epstein and Jean over here
criticized my part of it by saying that
I only answered it as an anarchist and
now I'm going to try both based on what
Jean said as an anarchist as Carrie said
yes we still have laws if if you steal
something even under an anarchist
Society you will be punished and now I
wanted and and the this analogy is of
one country invades another country the
reason we shouldn't invade Venezuela
is not because the Venezuelans are good
probably be a good thing if the Maduro
were deposed it's because now speaking
as a limited government person not as an
anarchist the function of the government
is to protect the people in the United
States not to go abroad and help the
Venezuelans
so I see a diss analogy there now just
because it's and I also reject this
analogy between the drug war I don't
think anyone should be penalized in the
drug war because it's a victimless crime
but this is not a victimless crime this
is a victim that the baby is a victim
this is just first-degree murder and if
it's difficult to look it's it's
difficult to find first-degree murders
ordinarily an adult kills another adult
it's not easy to find the person and and
prove beyond a reasonable doubt that
he's there should we get rid of the the
log against you know penalizing
murderers of course not well this is
murder this is downright plain murder to
kill a baby in the third trimester who
could live otherwise nice question hi I
first want to say that I really enjoyed
both speakers they're very erudite and
articulate and I've learned a lot from
both speakers that said the reason I
agree with Walter and disagree with
Kerry and the reason that the law of the
land
is allowing women to have control of
their bodies the reason I disagree with
you Kerry is that you really cannot
speak about women's rights and take your
position there is no way you can have
you have it both ways it's literally one
precludes the other and that's why I
agree with Walters position but I really
enjoyed your development of your ideas
very erudite very well that's good but
the statement carry water is you can't
talk about women's rights and have
Kerry's position do you want to address
that challenge carrier do you want to
pass what you want to say yeah you can
pass
you've got complimented I do I guess I'm
not sure I want to open that can of
worms you know my I I think women's
rights absolutely matter I don't think
that we live in a world where the
fetuses rights and the woman's rights
are opposed to one another I do think
that the way the current paradigm exists
has sort of taught us to think that way
and certainly
you I mean certainly you have have I'm
gonna criticize the pro-life side now
the pro-life side has definitely
downgraded the rights of women when it
comes to motherhood I think I mean I've
heard some absolutely absurd statements
come from them and I think they should
you know stop making those statements I
think they need to I mean you know that
first Curtis and when when I broke my
silence and I and I'm made that
constructive criticism against her life
movement I said what what the heck is
your goal is it to save fetal wives or
is it to prosecute women and because
those are two different things if we
want to end abortion if we want to save
lives
that means mitigating the felt need for
it that means the woman standing in her
bathroom staring herself down in the
mirror because she has a pregnancy
pregnancy she's not prepared to to have
we don't want her having to sit there
with a pill under her hands thinking
this is my only option right we want her
to have options and that's why I that's
why I think that the solution is in the
freed market we want to maximize her
options that way obviously I think that
she shouldn't have the right to kill her
fetus but the difference between my view
and I think the conservative pro-life
view is that the conservative Pro lifers
aren't actually trying to maximize her
options they're just trying to take away
this one thing which our society has
sort of said that's it
like if you have an unwanted pregnancy
it's no good options or abortion and I
don't want that for her either I want to
maximize her options and yeah we take
abortion away but maximize all of her
options over here so that she has the
best opportunity to to make a better
decision I hope that helps let me ask
Kerry a question what option would you
give to a woman a pregnant woman that
the conservative pro-life people
wouldn't or did I misunderstand you what
options would I give yeah well I think
part of the pro-life part of the
pro-life argument is that they
want to sort of get rid of this idea of
wanted this right the it's not it's not
good enough that a woman doesn't want
her pregnancy for them they want to
change her mind and get her to want a
pregnancy and that doesn't really work
right there are many good reasons to not
want to be pregnant and they're not
those aren't illegitimate and so they
have a tendency to vilify unwanted miss
they also have a tendency to say you
have to carry it to term now I would say
you have to carry it to viability at
least right so in that viability
yeah I agree we'll be moving back closer
and closer to conception we should
definitely move medical technology
forward that way so that would be
another way that that mine Maya my offer
is different than the pro the
conservative pro-life I hope that
answered it looks like we have time for
just one more question though
this question sir carry the when it
comes to the restitution for a rape
victim if the rape victim were to carry
to viability and the baby at that point
died during delivery would you hold the
rapists accountable for that death as
part of the restitution that's a good
question I guess that I guess the first
question I would I would respond with
was how did the baby die you know if it
was just a natural death I'm not sure
that you could hold there were the
rapist responsible for that you know but
if there was an unnatural death you
might but I don't know exactly we would
have to I'd have to look at the exact
circumstances one more question I guess
reason could I comment on what no please
no - I'm sorry we can't comment we just
have a question you can tell you you can
talk later with the carry
okay please question is for Walter in
relation to the idea that you can't have
an implicit contract with someone who
doesn't yet exist my question is if I
were to hire a hitman to murder the
children of someone even if those
children don't yet exist but then he
would carry that out when they were born
would I still be responsible for their
deaths well yeah I think so
I mean there's no implicit contrary it's
true the children don't yet live but you
paid this guy ten thousand dollars to
kill someone else's kids when they're
born you're a bad guy
nice try okay I don't meet you
personally that was a very perhaps the
most creative question of the evening is
that there's a note we're gonna hit on
Carrie do you have any comment on
murdering someone I know you probably
agree with Walter so what we we we have
concluded the QA and Walter gets to
summarize what do you carry and I was
speaking before the debate and we were
very friendly then and very friendly
throughout which is what I like and what
I said and she agreed with me on this is
that we're really doing two things here
one were having a debate it was a good
debate but we're doing something else
and that is we're engaging in a
cooperative venture not just the two of
us but the whole kit and caboodle here
to get that one millionth of an inch
closer to the truth with a capital T
that's what we're really trying to do
also I mean I'm not trying to deprecate
that it's a debate it is a debate but
part of the debate is give-and-take and
thesis antithesis synthesis and trying
to get a little bit more and I think
I've learned a lot from Carrie and I
hope she's learned a bit from me there
were several times that Jean wouldn't
allow me to speak he's a rotten kid no
respect I'm older than him he should
have more respect for me so I'll devote
some of my time to what I would have
said there was talk of women's rights
there no such thing as women's right
or men's rights no such thing as
handicapped people's rights or non
handicapped people's rights no such
thing as white rights or black rights or
fetus rights of adults right they're
just human rights and all we have
according to libertarianism is the right
not to be aggressive against and that's
it
so I don't think we should make such
distinctions there's another issue that
we didn't bring up and that's women's
health sometimes they say well you can
have an abortion if it's to save the
woman's life and there I agree I'm a
moderate that's why they call me wall to
moderate block I'm very moderate I mean
there was this example and one of the
things I read and some of these
philosophers are very ingenious and what
it said is suppose the baby starts
getting bigger and bigger and the baby
will get so big that it'll kill the
woman does the woman have a right to and
this is in the third trimester and the
only way to get the baby out of there is
to kill it first does the woman have a
right to do it and now what we have is
you can have both people live either the
baby lives or the woman lives and I say
the babies rights come second to the
woman's rights because the baby is a
trespasser so that would be the one case
where I support abortion not just the
eviction if it's to save the woman's
life I wanted to raise another issue
that Hasson also also hasn't been raised
and that is suppose you and your a
couple husband and wife you come home
you bring the baby from the hospital and
you leave it in in the baby's crib and
now you don't feed the baby and the baby
dies did you commit a crime and I say
you did you have an obligation to bring
that baby to a hospital and orphanage or
church or synagogue or or at least tell
somebody who might want the baby that
here's a baby available but doesn't this
conflict with no positive obligations
because I also have the view that there
are no positive obligation this sounds
positive obligation ish that you have a
right to get off your rear end you have
an obligation to get off your rear end
and take that baby to a fire station or
the police station or something and my
answer to that is bagel theory sometimes
I say donut theory but we're in New York
so it's bagel theory
so what's a bagel theory picture a bagel
can you homestead land in the babel
bagel format namely uu homestead this
but you leave a one square mile in the
middle of it no you can't why can't you
because then you would be controlling
I'm assuming no tunnels under no bridges
over and no pole vaulting no nothing no
helicopters you can't do that because
then you would be controlling on
homesteaded land and preventing other
people from getting it I once had a
Hasidic rabbi friend of mine we
discussed this and he said well if you
did the bagel theory you have to allow
egress through your property so people
can get there well what's that got to do
with the baby
what's that got to do with babies the
baby is like a hole in the middle of the
bagel it sounds a little awkward but you
know the point is that if you kept that
baby in the back room and didn't feed
the baby what you would be doing is
controlling a resource the baby that
other people want and you're no longer
homesteading it you see I believe that
you can have absentee ownership you own
when you can you can be an absentee
owner but with a baby it's different the
only way you can have the rights to be
the guardian of the baby is the guard
the baby and you stop guarding the table
as soon as you stop guarding the baby
you no longer have a right to that baby
so if you don't bring the baby to a an
orphanage or a hospital or something
like that what you're doing is similar
to what the guy who homestead it in a
bagel theory and you're not allowed to
do that
carrying your five minutes of summary so
about a month ago I read an article by
Caitlyn Flanagan at the Atlantic it's
entitled the dishonesty of the abortion
debate Flanagan captured the
quintessential nature of why coming to
consensus on abortion that appears
impossible she takes a pro-choice stance
but I admire her own brutal honesty
summed up in this statement the argument
for abortion is made if made honestly
requires many words
it must've oak the recent past the dire
consequences to women of making a very
simple medical procedure illegal the
argument against it takes not even a
single word the argument against it is a
picture end quote
so we know this is a baby we know it's a
human life we know it has rights and
certainly I would agree with Darwin with
Walter that there is no such thing as
women's rights now there are certainly
as rights of women and the rights of
women have been subjugated to the rights
of men to the rights of Arden to the the
interest of this state and even to the
rights of the fetus throughout history
this is true and so we've always had at
some point secondary status so when we
talk about the rights of women it's it
is meaningful it is not merely I think
this it's not merely this this idea of
self-ownership a woman does have self
ownership but that has been subjugated
throughout history and so what I'm what
I am arguing is that if we absolute eyes
the rights of the fetus and say it does
have a right to occupy the mother then
we are absolute izing the rights of
women we understand much more clearly
what is going on when she gets pregnant
we understand much
more clearly what is going on when she's
making decisions about her life about
her career about who she chooses to have
sex with and that sort of thing that has
so much more meaning when we understand
that what she is capable and capable of
is producing new self owners so by
absolute izing fetal rights we can
absolute eyes the rights of women and I
think that's what the libertarian
position on abortion is thank you thank
you to both of you it was indeed a
cooperative venture but it's also a
debate only one of you can win the
Tootsie Roll
could be a tie that's true that's true
and Reid had ties in the past it very
rarely happens but every once awhile it
does and I forgot to bring the tootsie
rolls I'm going to send them to you
later but we are now open to voting
Harvey yeah yeah okay yeah
and again you're voting finally on the
resolution while a pregnant woman should
be legally required to help the fetus
survive outside her body whenever that
is possible
she should retain the legal right to
evict the fetus and anytime during a
pregnancy yes/no or undecided for your
final vote while you're voting a couple
of plans a couple of retrospectives we
do have as Nick mentioned a dedicated
podcast called the solo forum debates
that you can access all the debates
we've ever had more than 35 are
available on that podcast we also have
videos of all of our debates I was very
gratified that the recent video I did
with Richard Wolff on socialism versus
capitalism has in the space of a little
over three weeks gotten over 200,000
views on YouTube and thank you
and I was personally pleased that I not
only won the debate by ask for style
rules
as my friend Rudolf Howser has said this
time I didn't yell at the guy as I did
at basco son kana when I debated him and
so I won without yelling and therefore
it was a very character-building
experience for me personally and so if
you haven't watched that debate between
me and Richard Wolff then you might want
to do so or go into these Sol Forum
debates podcast and listen to the debate
in Monday January 6th that's going to be
you know Civ 6 days after New Year's but
hopefully you will have sobered up by
then and that will be Monday January 6
best-selling author and Silicon Valley
entrepreneur Martin Ford will defend the
resolution robotics will soon lead to
widespread joblessness underemployment
and the concentration of wealth in the
hands of a few against Antony Samer off
co-host of the Scottish Liberty podcast
that's Monday January 6 tickets are on
sale for that Tuesday February 4th it's
going to be me again that's going to be
me against Heritage Foundation
distinguished senior fellow Stephen
Moore who will defend the resolution
president Trump's trade related
initiatives against China deserve broad
public support he will take the
affirmative I will be taking the
negative and there we will have Nick
Nick Gillespie returning as guest
moderator and uh her me interrupt me any
time you feel the devote is finalized
but also I Walter mentioned Richard
Epstein he's gonna make a comeback and
on March 7th
Monday March 7th we're getting Columbia
prophet Timmy Tim woo Tim Lewis was
quite prominent and he's from Columbia
he will he's author of the curse of
bigness and he will defend the
resolution antitrust should take the
initiative to control the size of the
big tech companies
and NYU Law Professor Richard Epstein
will be taking the negative that's on
March 7th and our big sellout event
where we're going to have a much larger
hole we're gonna have this one at John
Jay College where we had my original
debate with Vasco Sankara a hall that
sees 450 people more than double the
size of this hole that will be William
Kristol who has graciously come agreed
to debate at the Seoul forum William
Kristol wrote this resolution himself he
will defend the resolution a willingness
to intervene and to seek regime regime
regime change is key to an American
foreign policy that a benefits America
and the world against Scott Horton
author of fool's errand time to end the
war in Afghanistan once we announced
that we sold out very quickly for that
event so we decided we better have it in
a much larger Hall and tickets are still
available for that event I'll go on so
formed org to look at all our events
debates are scheduled through July of
next year at this time Hurley
do we have the results okay thank you
all right well okay the voting the yes
vote for the resolution was thirty three
point eight five percent that gained
thirteen point eight five points it went
up to 47 oh my god I mean it went off
actually yeah I haven't memorized it was
indeed very close you picked up a little
over 13 points and a carry picked up a
little over 12 points the difference you
had 30 Walter you had thirteen point
eight five percent that you picked up
Kerry picked up twelve point three one
it was very close it was difference of a
little over a point
Kerry ended up with 38
and of the vote Walter you ended up with
47% but Kari Walter gets the tootsie
roll